[MUSIC PLAYING]
Six lines of code
is all it takes
to write your first
Machine Learning program.
My name's Josh
Gordon, and today I'll
walk you through writing Hello
World for Machine learning.
In the first few
episodes of the series,
we'll teach you how to
get started with Machine
Learning from scratch.
To do that, we'll work with
two open source libraries,
scikit-learn and TensorFlow.
We'll see scikit in
action in a minute.
But first, let's talk quickly
about what Machine Learning is
and why it's important.
You can think of Machine
Learning as a subfield
of artificial intelligence.
Early AI programs typically
excelled at just one thing.
For example, Deep
Blue could play chess
at a championship level,
but that's all it could do.
Today we want to
write one program that
can solve many problems without
needing to be rewritten.
AlphaGo is a great
example of that.
As we speak, it's competing
in the World Go Championship.
But similar software can also
learn to play Atari games.
Machine Learning is what
makes that possible.
It's the study of
algorithms that
learn from examples
and experience
instead of relying
on hard-coded rules.
So that's the state-of-the-art.
But here's a much
simpler example
we'll start coding up today.
I'll give you a problem
that sounds easy but is
impossible to solve
without Machine Learning.
Can you write code to
tell the difference
between an apple and an orange?
Imagine I asked you to write
a program that takes an image
file as input,
does some analysis,
and outputs the types of fruit.
How can you solve this?
You'd have to start by
writing lots of manual rules.
For example, you
could write code
to count how many orange pixels
there are and compare that
to the number of green ones.
The ratio should give you a
hint about the type of fruit.
That works fine for
simple images like these.
But as you dive deeper
into the problem,
you'll find the real world
is messy, and the rules you
write start to break.
How would you write code to
handle black-and-white photos
or images with no apples
or oranges in them at all?
In fact, for just about
any rule you write,
I can find an image
where it won't work.
You'd need to write
tons of rules,
and that's just to tell the
difference between apples
and oranges.
If I gave you a new problem, you
need to start all over again.
Clearly, we need
something better.
To solve this, we
need an algorithm
that can figure out
the rules for us,
so we don't have to
write them by hand.
And for that, we're going
to train a classifier.
For now you can think of a
classifier as a function.
It takes some data as input
and assigns a label to it
as output.
For example, I
could have a picture
and want to classify it
as an apple or an orange.
Or I have an email, and
I want to classify it
as spam or not spam.
The technique to
write the classifier
automatically is called
supervised learning.
It begins with examples of
the problem you want to solve.
To code this up, we'll
work with scikit-learn.
Here, I'll download and
install the library.
There are a couple
different ways to do that.
But for me, the easiest
has been to use Anaconda.
This makes it easy to get
all the dependencies set up
and works well cross-platform.
With the magic of
video, I'll fast forward
through downloading
and installing it.
Once it's installed,
you can test
that everything is
working properly
by starting a Python script
and importing SK learn.
Assuming that worked, that's
line one of our program down,
five to go.
To use supervised
learning, we'll
follow a recipe with
a few standard steps.
Step one is to
collect training data.
These are examples of the
problem we want to solve.
For our problem, we're
going to write a function
to classify a piece of fruit.
For starters, it will take
a description of the fruit
as input and
predict whether it's
an apple or an orange as
output, based on features
like its weight and texture.
To collect our
training data, imagine
we head out to an orchard.
We'll look at different
apples and oranges
and write down measurements
that describe them in a table.
In Machine Learning
these measurements
are called features.
To keep things simple,
here we've used just two--
how much each fruit weighs in
grams and its texture, which
can be bumpy or smooth.
A good feature makes
it easy to discriminate
between different
types of fruit.
Each row in our training
data is an example.
It describes one piece of fruit.
The last column is
called the label.
It identifies what type
of fruit is in each row,
and there are just
two possibilities--
apples and oranges.
The whole table is
our training data.
Think of these as
all the examples
we want the classifier
to learn from.
The more training data you
have, the better a classifier
you can create.
Now let's write down our
training data in code.
We'll use two variables--
features and labels.
Features contains the
first two columns,
and labels contains the last.
You can think of
features as the input
to the classifier and labels
as the output we want.
I'm going to change the
variable types of all features
to ints instead of strings,
so I'll use 0 for bumpy and 1
for smooth.
I'll do the same for our
labels, so I'll use 0 for apple
and 1 for orange.
These are lines two and
three in our program.
Step two in our recipes to
use these examples to train
a classifier.
The type of classifier
we'll start with
is called a decision tree.
We'll dive into
the details of how
these work in a future episode.
But for now, it's OK to think of
a classifier as a box of rules.
That's because there are many
different types of classifier,
but the input and output
type is always the same.
I'm going to import the tree.
Then on line four of our script,
we'll create the classifier.
At this point, it's just
an empty box of rules.
It doesn't know anything
about apples and oranges yet.
To train it, we'll need
a learning algorithm.
If a classifier
is a box of rules,
then you can think of
the learning algorithm
as the procedure
that creates them.
It does that by finding
patterns in your training data.
For example, it might notice
oranges tend to weigh more,
so it'll create a rule saying
that the heavier fruit is,
the more likely it
is to be an orange.
In scikit, the
training algorithm
is included in the classifier
object, and it's called Fit.
You can think of Fit as being
a synonym for "find patterns
in data."
We'll get into
the details of how
this happens under the
hood in a future episode.
At this point, we have
a trained classifier.
So let's take it for a spin and
use it to classify a new fruit.
The input to the classifier is
the features for a new example.
Let's say the fruit
we want to classify
is 150 grams and bumpy.
The output will be 0 if it's an
apple or 1 if it's an orange.
Before we hit Enter and see
what the classifier predicts,
let's think for a sec.
If you had to guess, what would
you say the output should be?
To figure that out, compare
this fruit to our training data.
It looks like it's
similar to an orange
because it's heavy and bumpy.
That's what I'd guess
anyway, and if we hit Enter,
it's what our classifier
predicts as well.
If everything
worked for you, then
that's it for your first
Machine Learning program.
You can create a new
classifier for a new problem
just by changing
the training data.
That makes this approach
far more reusable
than writing new rules
for each problem.
Now, you might be wondering
why we described our fruit
using a table of features
instead of using pictures
of the fruit as training data.
Well, you can use
pictures, and we'll
get to that in a future episode.
But, as you'll see later
on, the way we did it here
is more general.
The neat thing is that
programming with Machine
Learning isn't hard.
But to get it right,
you need to understand
a few important concepts.
I'll start walking you through
those in the next few episodes.
Thanks very much for watching,
and I'll see you then.
[MUSIC PLAYING]